hey guys greg alba here gonna watch the
crisis on earth x part three of the four
part series could only show ten minutes
of it on youtube full reaction over at
our patreon if you want to go ahead and
check that out going to be putting all
full-length TV show reactions over at
our patreon one of our perks that we
have over there become a patron Oh check
today if you want to check it out anyway
let's watch this
[Music]
bisexual and now I had a daughter who
looked just like you
with a cinema compulsion
and I expose my family life
he likes Oliver
dark Oliver
[Music]
what's gonna save them
[Music]
yeah captain cold
[Music]
I was cool revealed man this hood sick
ass garage
[Music]
hey we're cutting it close up it was
great time really enjoy in the pot so
your letters first off we know I'm a tin
star but you can call me me oh and
there's a fantastic did you make that no
time to make you shine why
[Music]
well I believe he just answered your
question
see the single entity fires
[Music]
my let's go and what about yours
back on earth one what about you'd be
giving up any chance of ever seeing them
again leo
why are you pushing this hard we have
fought and bled and sacrificed for this
war many strangers show up and you're
willing to throw everything away from
the fate of the world is at stake so are
the lives of their loved ones that is
cool
oh yeah he works way better game yeah
totally totally worst way better great
sorry yeah
hey telly Orissa love it
[Music]
t1000
[Music]
[Music]
yeah just said t1000
turbinator that's puddy ladies hot women
[Music]
nice yeah kick-ass out
[Music]
just take this by using this it's the
Strongs duty to protect the weak did it
go
[Music]
yeah she'll be fine she has a cut
[Music]
a weapon is headed to blow up the
facility a weapon you mean a missile not
exactly
whoa Barry ray we know stop of flying
robots um how good the rest of us will
open the breach that's the whole plan
well that's a start we know used to say
make a plan execute the plan expect the
plan to go off the rails
throw away the plan wow that is terrible
he's not to leave this booth without me
[Music]
nice nice oh [ __ ] massacre in depth
[Music]
yeah what they gotta have sex again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa whoa
[Music]
okay let's go hold on that's an
automated power selling we need to
activate it or using a controller
console and how with no problem
then I'll turn on the console oh we want
to split up so terminals paper wads
let's kick some ass Jefferson
[Music]
really worried shot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
gary is so quick a loading that
[Music]
I'm so scared he's gonna get hurt
[Music]
No
really daddy hit damn I think because
it's a cliffhanger he'll probably be
alright Matt was a really good episode
it was a really good episode I really
loved it they're telling this one
specific story right now because the
first episode had you know it's heart
and light introduction in the beginning
with some minor dark elements in there
the second episode gets a lot darker you
get a little bit more detail into the
story and the reasoning for why earth
axe is invading earth 1 and then here
the fact that you get to explore a
little bit more of Earth X be involved
in the world of where the Nazis have
taken over earth and they're ruling
everything I like when movies deal with
historical fiction or taking a play on
what if Nazis had one taking it into
this arrowverse is a really interesting
endeavor and dark Cara whatever her name
is and I really care for in the first
two episodes but the scene where I think
Melissa Benoist but no I think I say
it's in her name good car and bad car
interacting with each other actually
really bought her dialogue there and I
like how this show is doing a lot of
that you know you get a lot of hope and
because the way how we've seen these
shows play out before you think okay
they have this mission they're gonna go
do it they're gonna handle business and
everything's gonna be fine in the end
but it seems like the more they keep
getting progress there's always a major
setback like with felicity and iris
turning off the power you think alright
they're just gonna save Supergirl get
her out of there but then it all goes to
[ __ ] right away even with them trying to
get to this breach the robots coming in
there and they lost their fight to them
you're thinking okay flash and em are
gonna save the day but then they don't
like the intensity and the stakes are
really felt to the point where I started
thinking they might kill off a main
character here now Martin Stein I don't
know if he's actually gonna be dead the
fact that they ended on a note where oh
it's been Shaw we don't see him died
it's probably just a cliffhanger that's
making you come back for the next
episode as opposed to him actually dying
I don't have to wait and see for the
next episode and I really like what they
did with Lance here being the general
that was great he's such a great actor
and I don't really know anything else Oh
see him in outside of arrow but seeing
him here was a great twist I wish we had
a little bit more scenes with Sara Lance
and the Jen
interacting with each other because you
know they do a lot of these moments
where earth one interacts with earth X
version and the relationship is
different on earth one day toy with that
and I thought we might have gotten a
little bit more of that but maybe they
just don't have time for that there's
only four episodes there's such a wide
variety characters but what they utilize
them for here I thought was very
effective and I forgot that Felicity is
Jewish and they they utilize that to the
effect of the Nazis taking over the
world
I thought it was a great scene she had
so my prediction for the next episode is
Cisco and the team is probably gonna
break out of the cells or in and save
the day save Cara say Felicity's singing
Iris captain snark I love him you know
he sent like it over the top actor but I
can't help but enjoy the hell out it
wasn't he Wentworth Miller Captain Cold
making him gay was great it just fits
way more with the characters so glad
they did that oh yeah it's nice seeing
him return all right I'll watch the next
one so if you want to see this full
reaction you can go over to patreon and
it's the only place I could put it up
the whole thing so you can subscribe to
the real rejects in the meantime click
that notification bell to get notified
any time one of our videos is up and
yeah become a patron ejected a a lot
more than there's over 300 exclusive
posts over there right now
and it's really become a big part of our
lives so go check it out